these are AR glasses I'm going to put
them on so that you can see what I look
like in them these little covers come
off so I can see you now oh okay and
these basically allow you to put a
screen in your your field of view if you
want you look cool thanks dude here you
want to look at these yeah I
do okay
oh yeah oh what do you think I'm
watching an anime this is great but
eventually I think you could be wearing
the Apple cap and it is just putting
that signal into your optical nerve yeah
optical nerve did you say I'm listening
to very loud anime whoa he's stabbing
that guy puked blood everywhere thank
you that was incredible well what' you
buy I got myself a new fanny pack
Chad